[Music]  in our new series hawkeye clint barton  may have met his equal with his new  teammate kate bishop that's debatable  but right now we're going to see who's a  better marksman me or haley you're going  down runner i want to see about that  [Applause]  [Music]  thank you come on  no i swear  i this is a joke  this is rigged ha it's not i'm just  kidding  you got it  yeah baby  cornhole  pizza jaw corn hole all right  nice  close  good defense though  okay  [Music]  [Applause]  what's next  [Music]  oh there it is yeah actually it's just  tremendous with that oh damn even  looking  oh there you go  well that was fun more fun than shooting  exploding arrows no of course not  nothing's more fun than that